it's time to have a little fun here on a
friday we're joined now
from the mix 94.1 studios live with las
vegas now host mercedes martinez
good morning mercedes it's time to talk
about what's trending including
some new shows from disney yes john
great to see you this morning that's
right disney made some huge
announcements
at its 2020 investor day yesterday one
division the first
marvel studio show on disney plus got a
new trailer
of its upcoming january 15th release
date it was also confirmed
that black panther ii will not recast
the late chadwick boseman's king
t'challa the film is still set for a
july 22 release and a third ant-man film
ant-man and the wasp
quantum mania is officially in
development
now about 10 star wars series are coming
to disney plus
including spin-offs of the mandalorian
called ahsoka
and rangers of the new republic and this
is big news hayden christensen
is returning as darth vader in obi-wan
kenobi
also taylor swift dropped another new
album last night called
evermore she also released this music
video for one of the songs called willow
she says evermore is the sister record
to folklore which she just released
about five months ago swiss said she
just couldn't stop writing now john i
know you are a
huge taylor swift fan right i mean
obviously i've
been trying to restrain myself from
listening to taylor swift 24
7 uh during quarantine pandemics but i
know a lot of fans are very stoked that
she's back so good to see
she's putting out more content and maybe
i'll become a taylor swift fan
let's switch gears talk about a british
chef going viral this morning mercedes
yeah this is really funny nigella lawson
she was explaining how to make something
when she said it check this out now i'm
aiming
for quite a solid mash at this stage but
i still need
a bit of milk full fat which i've warmed
in the microwave
yeah you heard that right and by
microwave
she means microwave now people are
wondering if that's how she really
pronounces it or if she was just being
kind of cheeky
well the chef tweeted well i do say it
like that
but not because i think that's how it's
actually pronounced can this be the end
of it now
the answer is no it cannot be the end of
it
what is that well i'm i guess the
question would be if she bought her
microwave at target
oh there you go see maybe she was just
trying to pull the target on as i like
it
she couldn't get a good deal at walmart
so she had to go to target and buy her
microwave to make her mash
why are you you are so freaking witty i
love it
like how did you think about it so fast
well i think we're going to start
calling it a microwave from now on i
think it'll be a trend that will take
effect
i think if we start mercedes you and i
we're going to make this happen
teamwork makes the dream work i'm on it
and i'll send it back to you at
shawnellate
and mix94 uno